hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game between Magnus Carlsen and
Jordan fan Forest it's from the
ancientious rapid which is the fourth
event of the two million dollar uh uh
Champions Chester that features three
divisions one of eighteen one of 16 and
one of 32 players and what's interesting
about this tournament is that it doesn't
matter if you lose a match uh you just
drop down on division but you can still
climb up and actually win the match it
uh each uh division consists consists of
a double elimination knockout where like
I said if you lose you can bounce back
so that being said let's check it out
this is the second game of their match
first game was uh just uh just a brutal
grind by Magnus he won a completely
equal night and pawn end game uh over
the course of some 82 moves I believe uh
and you know it was just hard to watch
and this is now a second game uh where
uh Jordan will have a chance to bounce
back with the black pieces as Magnus
also defeated him with black in the
first round so let's check it out we do
have quite a bit of theory some 15 moves
but then we will of course uh reach new
territory so upon the E4 upon the E5 by
Jordan Knight F3 Knights the C6 and
Bishop to B5 so Magnus goes for the rui
Lopez Knight to F6 the Berlin defense
and now Magnus castles we have Knight
captures on e4 and Rook to E1 and this
is the so-called Rio Gambit accepted
variation Knight to D6 and Knight
captures on E5 with Bishop t7 Bishop
back to F1 and now uh of course Knight
captures on E5 Rook captures and now
castles we have found the D4 and Bishop
to F6 in many many games in the database
with um these exact moves nothing new
being played here rookie one rook d8 and
now Bishop to F4 uh you're in trades
with Rook captures Queen captures uh and
now Knight to E8 we have won the C3
defending the D4 Pawn here and pawn to
D5 uh mag Jordan wants to have a similar
setup here we have Knights the D2 and
pawn to C6 and there are some games for
Bishop to D3 was played also Queen to E3
is a known move but here we have Pawn to
A4 and it is now as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game so okay Ponte
5 of course stopping B4 this is
essential with Bishop to D3 and now Pawn
to G6
um diminishing the power of the bishop
on D3 and also making room for the
Knight to come to G7 and then to F5 or
maybe the bishop will come to F5 all
depends on what Magnus plays so Knight
to F3 and now Knights the G7 with Bishop
to H6 and now uh Bishop to E6 it's a
very interesting uh what Magnus would do
if Knight F5 was played for example
probably he would just go back obviously
maybe giving up the bishop pair so early
not what you want to do it it is a rapid
game after all but okay instead Bishop
D6 was played quanta H3 and now Queen to
D6 preparing to bring the Rook into the
game so Queen to D2 of course Magnus
knows that Jordan will develop the rook
and the only open file on the board so
Rook the E8 we have Rook D1 country in
the rook and E8 and now Queen to d8
uh you've uh you're nicely protecting
your rook and also if the position opens
up with some C4 at some point okay maybe
the A5 Pawn will be defended so it's a
good Square for the queen we have Pawn
to G4 Magnus grabs more space on the
king side and Bishop to C8 now uh Jordan
just offers a trade of Rooks Magnus
obligence Rook captures Knight captures
and now Queen to F4 just uh improving
the position of the queen grabbing more
space queen to C7 offering a queen trade
and while Magnus doesn't actively trade
he also doesn't mind the trade so he
just improves the position of his King
we have Queen captures on F4 Bishop
captures and now Bishop to E7 we have
Pawn to G5 very interesting move and the
Very uh committal move by Magnus of
course uh pawns are one of those uh the
the only piece that once it goes forward
it cannot go back unless it becomes
something else okay then uh you can go
wherever you want pretty much but as
long as it's a pawn it can only go
forward and the idea of course is
Advance the H Pawn s further as far as
possible so Bishop to D6 offering
further trades and Magnus just improves
his position 95 beautiful centralizing
move King f8 bringing the king uh closer
to the action and now Pawn to H4 we have
King to A7 and now even Pawn to H5 now
you can see how Bishop is doing good
work here if you capture an H5 then
Bishop will capture on H7 and then you
will go after uh this uh H5 captured
Pawn so Knight the G7 attacking H5 uh
kind of asking Magnus Title capture on
G6 or Advance the pawn and Magnus
advances it pawn to H6 with Knight to E6
now attacking the bishop and Bishop to
E3 nicely controlling all of the squares
that the Knight can go to so Knight back
to f8 now the Knight can be shifted to
D7 to challenge the Knight and E5 and
King to F3 Magnus just improves the
position of his King we have Bishop F5
and now finally Magna straight with
Bishop captures g-captors uh Jordan
willingly uh messes up his Pawn
structure but it was the only active
plan uh for for black to go for Knight
to D3 uh also very nicely played by
Magnus guards the B4 Square now B4 is
coming you cannot stop that Knight to E6
and now Pawn to B4 Magnus agrees with
the engine it is the strongest move for
white to play a capture some B4 we have
C count for some B4 and now Pawn to F4
uh looks like a pawn sacrifice but it's
not as the bishop also guards the D4
pawn and also this prevents the Bishop
from guarding the G5 Pawn which leads us
to a very important question Bishop
captures on F4 was played Bishop
characters Knight captures and now uh
which Pawn would you capture would you
capture the D4 Pawn uh or would you
capture the G5 Pawn everything you know
about Chess is telling you to capture
the D4 Pawn it's a Central Pawn it
creates a pass Pawn I mean there's no
reason not to capture the D4 Pawn except
here there is as it loses the game uh
one problem is if you capture on D4 uh
then you allow the king to come up the
board for example King to G4 and now how
do you continue if you move the Knight
the king can go to F5 if uh you don't
want to do that let's say you play
Knight to C2 you attack the B4 Pawn you
play Knight D3 okay you guard the B4
Pawn but now the Knight also cannot move
because then you play Knight to C5 and
you pick up the B7 Pawn so what can you
do of course you can make the king move
but now King the F4 cutting off the
black king from going any further also
the pawn covers this and there really
aren't all that many squares if the king
moves then you gain even more space king
a five King F6 and so on if the Knight
moves Knight the C5 now comes with check
you'll pick up the B7 Pawn so it's a one
of those weird chess positions where the
move you all wanted to play unless some
of you act actually want to play Knight
captures in G5 then you have Grand
Master Level uh in-game understanding
which is of course what Jordan played he
played Knight captures on G5 check and
that is the way to go uh King the G4 and
now Knights the E4 challenging the F2
Pawn so Knights the D3
uh defends the F2 Pawn as well as the B4
pawn and now Knight the C3 attacking the
A4 Pawn but Magnus just advances at Pawn
to A5 and now uh to uh to actually
continue playing this as it is equal
material it's sort of an equal end game
Knights the E4 should be played now this
kind of prevents the knight from moving
as the F2 Pawn is hanging so you have to
advance and then you move the Knight
let's say with the checking 497 and the
game continues now white is always a
little bit better as white controls more
space but you you can still fight
however after night the B5 he allows
Magnus to go for Knight to C5 and now
okay he does win the D4 Pawn but he will
lose the B7 Pawn which means that Magnus
will have uh the past a pawn which also
doesn't sound that bad and now the
problem is Knight captures on the
fortnite captures on B7 and knights the
B5 it doesn't really look like there's a
realistic chance of you advancing this
Pawn because how are you crossing the A7
Square for the white Knights to actually
guard the A7 Square it would have to be
on B5 or in C6 and that's impossible or
or on C8 how are you getting it to C8 I
mean or C6 uh it doesn't really doesn't
really work so okay Point A6 maybe you
could play Knight A5 to C6 but now King
to E6 Jordan plays correctly he says uh
yeah there's no way to do this but
Magnus finds a way and there is a way he
plays King to F4 and now we have Knight
the A7 uh uh just you know blocking the
position and controlling everything but
the position is now completely winning
for Magnus but you have to figure out
why feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning idea for Magnus uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight to d8 with Czech of course is
the first move you thought of but it's
the second move that counts in the
variation here of course King t7 was
played if you play King to these to the
Knight captures here then you pick up
the H7 pawn and you just win with the H
Pawn however after King the E7 the movie
you had to find was Knight captures on
C6 with check forcing the Knight to be
captured this is what Magnus played
Jordan recaptured now Magnus plays Pawn
to B5 and the pawns are now Unstoppable
doesn't matter where you go to if you go
to A7 then you just Advance the pawn
Knight the C6 A7 and the pawn now
becomes a queen or in the case of the
game Knight the D4 was played now comes
spawn to A7 and now Knight to E6 with
check King to G3 preventing all further
checks and he was in this position on
move 51 that Jordan fund Forest resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here the problem is although you
can play Knight to C7 and the Guardians
where B6 just kicks away the Knight and
that's it Knight to a B7 and that's it
you can Queen pretty much whatever
whichever Pawn you want and that's it
you have uh you have you have many
queens you can even Queen this pawn and
this pawn and this pawn it is possible
that's just how good your position is
yeah after working the G3 Jordan
resigned and that means they went into
game three of the match but their game
ended in a draw which meant of course
that there is no way for Jordan to win
the match so he goes down at the vision
but doesn't mean anything he can still
bounce back and win the tournament as
it's uh you know that that's the kind of
tournament it is so if you're interested
in the other uh pairings uh sorry let me
just fix this a little bit I don't know
why it's weird like that
uh so there we have it
defeated Wesley saw with three to two uh
Ariana defeated feroza with a two and a
half to one and a half uh caruana
defeated with two and a half to half and
Magnus also defeated euron Panthers with
two and a half and a half so it will be
uh in the semi-finals Magnus Carlsen uh
versus Fabiano caruana and lebonarian
versus
and in the losers round we will have uh
so Wesley Soul versus fedossa and into
it will it Saga versus Jordan fan forest
for a chance to bounce back um
the main event
uh so yeah uh very nicely done by Magnus
after winning that grueling end game
with round one if you have a chance to
check it out like he he really won an
unwinnable game uh he does it again in
in round two but you know he he did just
uh completely obliterate that super
United tournament in Croatia and uh now
you know he's uh you know definitely in
the zone he he's uh still uh uh fully
well prepared so uh you know it was it
was just uh Jordan who who came first to
to the you know experience the full
Wrath of Magnus uh that's right once
again I really really hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank James Eugene
Cashman uh Paul Miller Brad Roth Michael
Marshall and bullet just thriller.com
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here and thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the the coverage of uh pretty
much everything that's happening in the
Chess World and of course uh my favorite
checking up your wonderful suggestions
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day